[Music]
you know I hope to not always be able to
be back on The Bachelor branches right
now I am the hottest show on television
is about to get cold what's changed from
two years ago a little bit more
confidence a little bit more humility
because I realize that I have a ton of
weaknesses that I need to work on and I
have been working when you're the
bachelor surprisingly your head can get
really big and you get pumped up and you
you lose yourself at times and so now
you know in life now I've taken a step
back I really did go into the bachelors
thinking I was gonna find somebody and I
did with this I'm kind of going into it
with a different mindset I'm here to
have fun first do you feel like you got
a big head as the bachelor cuz I never
got that vibe from you it's interesting
to hear you say that I think as the
bachelor I closed off a lot of the
insecurities or push back a lot of my
weaknesses because I didn't want the
women who had traveled a long ways it's
been a lot of time to see my failures
and faults I was nervous that if I were
to be too vulnerable to release too many
insecurities that they would turn turn
away and said that is not baggage or
somebody I want to deal with you have
been through a split what are you
looking for in a woman as you do head on
to the show I'm looking for somebody
that has my back and I can have there's
somebody that will love me through those
weaknesses and insecurities I was
talking about somebody that I can love
through their weaknesses and
insecurities I'm looking for not just a
friend but a romantic partner to now
adventure through life with I don't see
myself getting engaged that kind of is
you know that is another thing
engagement is very is a very big deal to
me
that would not be a wise decision if you
see me and
winter games on down on one knee either
you know wow that is really true true
true true love or there's loss of mine
[Music]